i think you should go hard on this i so
you have a hundred thousand listeners a
month you're making
single-digit thousands of dollars
you would make like six figures a year
for sure doing this
[Music]
um all right good so
sean what's good what's going on what's
up what's up you got ben still on the
line what do you what do you got for ben
normally you're like so heat turn off
your video we need to focus
i'm going to tell you why so ben made a
comment to me
maybe to you too i think you were here
like a while ago a month or two months
ago and i've been thinking a lot about
it and he kind of made it not a big deal
but it's kind of a big deal to me so
uh ben i'm not i'm not gonna i'm i'm
gonna only i haven't told you i'm gonna
bring up this bring this up i'm only
gonna like kind of mention the thing and
then you could you could kind of explain
how you want to but basically ben wilson
has this podcast called how to take over
the world and
you said that a very wealthy person like
a hundreds of millions of dollars person
has you on retainer and basically tells
you the strategy that this person's
going to do in business and you tell him
stories from history to let him know
what you predict will happen is that
right what
yes yes
he made is that crazy
he didn't explain it that way but that's
exactly what happened
it's like a sugar daddy but it's like a
history daddy
like a history baby i guess sugar baby
okay that's true did i get that act did
i explain that yeah so here's the full
story i get a lot of people who reach
out to me
at this point basically any fan who's
like hey can i talk to you for a little
bit i'm just like yeah i'm not that big
yet if you're big enough that you want
to if you i think i'm important enough
that you wanna talk to me yeah i'll talk
to you that's starting to change a
little bit a lot of people want my time
now but this was a while ago
um
and so i said yes i'll talk to you
he's like i'm thinking of starting
something out to talk to you about it i
was like okay this guy's probably a
joker but whatever he reached out to me
i'll talk to him so
we hop on a zoom and first thing
like he's
got a glass wall behind him and you can
tell he's in like a very very very high
high rise
in new york city you can see the whole
skyline behind him so immediately i was
like this is not what i thought it was
going to be
and uh so he was like yeah i'm a
managing director at xyz bank one of the
biggest banks in the world um
and i lead their
x division very very big uh
financial division at this big bank and
he's like i just randomly found your
podcast and you don't know this but i've
been listening to you you're my guru now
so i want to talk to you about like what
i'm thinking of starting and i just want
to bounce it off you and see
um what you think about it and so
he gets to call me whenever he wants to
and that sounds more normal sam was
saying he specifically wants you to tell
him based on history here's what's going
to happen is that that's when that's
what you you met you go you said you
said that yeah like i said i explain it
differently but that's what's going on
here like he likes you and he wants you
to like tell him like how would julius
caesar handle this or how did julius
caesar handle this tell me like what
what to do that's that's basically the
angle he's going for yeah because he
knows me from how to take over the world
so yeah oh my god that is amazing
isn't that awesome well first of all
hopefully me laughing about it doesn't
blow this for you uh but
but wow okay
but listen i want to ask you more
questions about this man but i had the
same reaction sean i was like what that
sounds like a scam
but i've been thinking a lot about this
and i actually think that's a great idea
i think that that is a wonderful idea
what do they say history may not repeat
itself but it definitely rhymes if
you're gonna tell people what behaviors
to avoid or like how other people have
had the same move and what happened i
think that's great how much is he paying
you
zero
what
i think he's paying you i thought you
were like a retainer no no no no he's
paying me so he so
he offered to pay me and i so much of
the offer how much did he offer
um
well he didn't offer explicitly but he's
he said he said
people
he said people who do what you do who
who consult people like me often make
upwards of five thousand dollars an hour
uh i don't think you would pay me
because i've never done it before i'm
not like a high level coach but i was
like well that's a pay range i was not
considering i must admit um but he said
i will pay you but then uh
i ended up telling him no don't worry
about it and uh
i just think it's better to have the
connection and have him think that he
owes me at this point okay
that's fine i but i actually think that
there's like is something interesting
here like because like alex friedman or
like these like thinker type folks like
they definitely could get paid 5 or 10
grand an hour
yeah but this to me is more like when
you the way you described it it's more
like you know in billions or whatever
it's like the guy's got a kink and he
goes to like get dominated by some
shaking a mask with a whip uh to me it's
more like that where it's like some rich
guy is just like hey uh i need you to
when i call you i need you to tell me
that i'm i'm a huge fuck-up and i suck
and that's gonna motivate me to go into
this meeting and prove myself daily and
i will pay you two thousand dollars an
hour if you are a hot woman who tells me
uh you know i suck and you spit on the
webcam to me that's that's more where
the opportunity is than like telling me
about lessons from history
no this is good because it's like let's
say that um he's like i'm working on
this thing my opinion of it is this this
and this and he and ben goes well you
know rothschild he actually the reason
why they did really well because they
just got information just a little bit
faster and they did this this and this
business is so context dependent it's
not like you actually need the
strategies of the roth house or julius
caesar i don't think i think it's
motivational to hear these stories right
like i i use one story why does it
matter if it's motivational or if it's
like strategically well that's actually
accurate because you got to know what am
i delivering right what am i actually
selling this person am i selling them
strategies from the 19 you know 1830s or
am i selling them that hey you know for
example ben i use this anecdote you have
from from how to take over the world
where you talked about um
you know edison used to go edison used
to be like he was amazing he was like
had done so much by the age of 25 and
he's like um
you know but nikola tesla had already
done xyz by this age i'm so behind and
even though he was the greatest inventor
of our age he personally felt behind
because he was comparing himself to
someone and then he read that julius
caesar used to go look at a statue of
alexander the great and be like what the
am i doing with my life alexander
the great already ruled you know
the world by now
and to me that lesson was like
you know that was actually a pretty
important lesson a lot of people feel
like they're behind or feel like they
they compare themselves to others who
are doing better it's like dude there's
no end to that julius caesar used to do
that and feel that way so you know
that's a trap you know that there is no
amount where you'll stop feeling that
way so might as well just let it all go
but that's kind of the same thing you're
just talking about life strategy i mean
it's kind of yeah i agree with you i'll
tell you how it actually went because
because what you said sean actually
plays into it that he said i'm thinking
about starting this thing it's
a higher possible outcome but if i stay
where i am right now it's just a more
steady like i can go from whatever i can
go from
220 to 500 hopefully in the next 10
years um but i'm not gonna become a uh
billionaire essentially um
but if i go start my own thing i could
lose a lot of money
what does 220 mean
220 million
oh that's what he's worth
no i'm i am
saying number i'm not going to tell you
what he's worth but he's but it is in
the hundreds of millions sounded pretty
specific to me all right
sounded like not a made-up number all
right
and so and so he was essentially like
should i do this thing
so i tell him i i talk about the i
talked about the concept of exactly what
you're saying
of like so much pressure on you to say
something that's not stupid
i was literally as he was saying this i
was like
why the hell are you talking to me
like it was so funny to me but he loved
the podcast he thought i'd have
something interesting to say so i
was like literally just grasping in my
head i'm panicking a little bit i'm like
what am i gonna say to this guy and so i
start talking before i even know what
i'm gonna say i said uh okay well have
you heard of
loss aversion and i
brought up the idea of loss of version
which i'm sure you heard of that he
hadn't heard a lost version so i
explained to him a little bit what loss
of version was explain it for somebody
who's listening who doesn't want to go
so a loss aversion is the idea that um
that you value
not losing your money
more than you value gaining money so
you put more emphasis on it so i
essentially said
you need
to
make loss aversion
work for you essentially if you believe
that you're going to be successful
then um
you need to
visualize that success
and say to yourself
and realize every day that you delay
starting your your new thing is going to
make you billions you're losing millions
of dollars
because you're you're failing to act
and uh he was like
that was amazing that's changed my whole
perspective he was he was blown away
i think that you're doing something
that's like so common which is and i do
it too you uh sean does not do this you
uh
you you are putting too low value you're
playing
yeah you're not really how it ends
though let me tell you how it ends so um
it was like a month later i was in new
york city so i said let's meet up let's
get lunch we went to a really nice
restaurant and he bought me lunch which
was very nice and i was like so when are
you starting the thing and he's like
well i'm not actually doing it and he
like gave his reasons why he's not he's
not starting it yet and i was like okay
well it sounded good when it came out of
my mouth but apparently my advice was
not that valuable
your spit is watered drink it exactly
that's when you need to go dominatrix
dude it's a yin and yang good cop bad
cop sort of thing
i think by the way i think that version
thing i think the numbers are two to one
meaning
you you'd have to make two dollars for
to feel the same as losing one you'd
have to make two thousand to feel the
same level of emotional hit as as losing
1000 would be i don't know if that's
but i've read that that's the
ratio of like how much we value
lost more than gain
sean do you get asked to consult and
like do this type of stuff i get asked
i'd never consult anymore but uh i
basically run a simple filter which is
would i do this for free that doesn't
mean i'm gonna do it for free it's would
i do this for free so for ben and ben's
case ben's like oh this sounds like a
super interesting guy
he did do it forever i'm gonna learn as
much from this guys he's gonna learn
from me if not more so you know i'm
happy to to do my do this with my time
so that that's one thing and then the
second part is
dude you get paid crazy money for doing
this type of like uh sam you do
these glg calls have you done any of
these i i i used to i think i was
getting paid a thousand dollars an hour
yeah exactly i set my rate at the max
that they let up let me do which is now
two thousand thousand two thousand
that's what it was and um
and dude i'll get paid two thousand
bucks to just do like a forty minute
call with some re like first of all it's
kind of funny because they're like it is
this like weird underground dominatrix
where it's like i'm a hedgehog
manager i can't tell you the fun i can't
tell you what i'm looking at i can't
tell you my name but like it's like a
once it's a one-way transaction it's
like i'm the masseuse and they're laying
face down i can't see who they are and
um and then they're like
okay say the word metaverse and i'm like
metaverse
tell me tell me who's gonna who who's
which stock's gonna go up because of the
metaverse i'm like dude i don't
know and they're like what and i'm like
yeah but i could tell you you know
here's some things i i think well well
whenever i do those things i talk really
slow yeah because you just need an hour
to pass
yeah
you i always talk really slow and i'll
be like wait hang on let me get my
headphones
the better way
i can't talk slow it's like i'm too
nervous like like i said with ben
you feel a tremendous amount of pressure
it doesn't really matter how much money
you have when somebody's paying you
something i would never pay someone two
grand for a phone call even though i'm
sure there's an economic case where it
makes sense it's just a big number to me
to just pay for somebody to talk to me
uh i'm so i'm so i'm so not used to it
that when i'm on the other side i'm
getting paid i'm like
i need to deliver this guy like some
insane insight that they've and i put
this weird pressure that just is
unachievable but i'll be like i'll say
my point and i really only have one
point and i'll be like another way of
thinking about it is
that i'll repackage the same idea with
like some metaphor or some analogy just
to fill air space because like like in
reality it's one idea that that's worth
it for them or not and i don't have like
10 amazing ideas i have one around one
topic you know i don't have but there's
there's a there's that's why ben shtick
is amazing because sean well you can
only consult on your life experience and
you like you can't live that interesting
of a life all the time and whereas ben
can just steal he could just read a book
a week and he's going to have like you
know 52 new ideas a year
the thing that this guy was trying to
sell me on was that i should come up and
speak to his
bank
um
and he's like you could get paid like
easy like 50 grand a pop to come up and
give sure that's the point
and i do 10 grand for a zoom at home to
give a speech to somebody now um and how
many of those and now i'm like why am i
not doubling my price like uh if they're
not saying yes i need to basically the
pricing strategy is if unless half the
people are saying no you're priced way
too low and so right now everybody's
saying yes why not price double that
i i did one recently it was 25 000 but
it was in person
yeah
yeah how many of those zooms
how many zooms a month do you do not
even one a month one every two months
probably is the the current
that's pretty sick to me though
yeah oh it's great it's i mean it's like
it's great money because
there's this other thing ben i don't
know what the what the history or
psychology will tell us about this but
there's extra joy in making money when
you can assign what that money gets to
go to
versus just generally making money and
it's going to go into a general pot of a
bank account versus like oh 10 grand all
right if i'm like i do these two
speeches this week this month i'll go
buy that car or i'll go get my wife this
gift and she's like wow that's great
that hey this this work you did was
awesome and uh i don't know what the
name for that metaphor is but i abused
the out of that
consumerism
just consumerism
so
you guys can tell me if there's ever a
moment like the reason i'm not doing any
of this stuff is i just feel fraudulent
like going up there and that's normal
but yeah maybe i just need to get over
it i don't know 100 you need to get over
it uh like the way you should think
about things is most of your life you're
basically underpaid um you're you're
underpaid and underappreciated
and um you know the universe has this
way of evening itself out where like um
you know sam will make more money off of
like some random investment he thought
about for five minutes uh than he would
of you know grinding some business that
he his apartment
finder business he did for two years or
three years and so like you know the
inputs don't always match the outputs in
life and once you sort of acknowledge
that you accept that that's like the
first thing you have to acknowledge
which is like
the level of difficulty for me is not
what dictates the value for somebody
else so that's number one yeah the the
the effort is not in proportion to the
output it's irrelevant all that matters
is the output the fact that you know
input is a liability for you uh it is a
weird psychological liability you would
be better off not knowing how hard it
was to say that one thing to that guy at
that moment
the second thing is that
you know mr market will decide what it's
worth and like you might be you might
get lucky once you might get lucky twice
but if people consistently pay you for
something it's because that's what it's
worth to them if not it's worth not
being worth more right they need they
need a positive roi on that on that
interaction and so just let the market
decide and the market over time will
balance itself out maybe maybe one one
off yeah that was just a fluke but if it
happens consistently enough and you
should just expect it to happen
consistently then it works
i i i think you should lean into this
hardcore because how much money are you
making on ads for your pi
say the numbers can you say the number
do you want to do it or no
um
yeah i guess i have one sponsor right
now
it's full punch punch shout out club
lunch go to the culture
sam is the one carrying that sponsorship
use code ben wilson
for i don't remember how much off 150
off something like that
um
so i will say i'm making uh four four
digits per month low four digits
okay so
one to
five thousand a month
um by the way also the hack when
somebody says how many digits just take
the bottom three numbers of that range
so if i say i make seven figures i'm
saying one to three million if sans we
sold for eight figures it's ten to
thirty million if somebody say hey right
like nobody if you're over half you're
you usually say it differently once
you're once you cross the uh if you
cross over 50 million you would say
over 50 million not
eight figures
or like the figures can include the uh
dot zero zero yeah there you go
that's a figure
nine figure exit bro
um so i think you should go and do this
ben i think that you should include i
think you should go hard on this so you
have a 100 000 listeners a month you're
making
single digit thousands of dollars
you would make like six figures a year
for sure do your own ad read which
basically says
look yes you listen to this and i you
know people who listen to this tell me
they got a bunch of inspiration they got
uh you know some strategies they got um
they you know they filled in the gaps of
something they didn't know about history
and they can see you know their place in
the world today through that whatever
blah blah blah some and you
basically say uh you know i used to run
ads for you know cold plunges by the way
use code ben wilson at checkout if you
if you want uh but you know actually
what ended up happening and you just
basically say this is what this is what
ended up happening
companies started hiring me to come in
and talk to them about lessons from the
greatest you know the greatest blah blah
in history and um it's motivational for
the executive team it's a great addition
to any off-site blah blah blah and so
that actually ends up making me more
money than the ads so if that if you're
interested in that you should contact me
blah blah i bet if you do that you'll
get one of these a month and it will
quadruple your current ad um you know ad
revenue for the
month dude you got to do this man you've
got to do this
okay next next month uh
we'll do another segment in uh ben's
first million and uh and
look
you can make it as simple so my best
friend neville medora he has the things
that he calls consults and if you go to
his blog like copywriting course.com
like consult there's just like a
checkout page and it's a thousand
dollars and you booked one hour with
them and you just you pay and then you
just like select on calendly and then
every like tuesday and thursday from
like 9am to like one he just knows that
he does that's his call time and uh he
makes a lot of money from it a year you
could do it as simple as that the other
thing by the way you need to do like a
profile of how to check for the world of
like uh i think you know you've done
jobs but i think if you do like pixar uh
right and you say you know here's
pixar's kind of creativity uh process
how pixar consistently has creative hits
and um you know storytelling or
something like that that opens the door
for you to basically teach the pixar way
to a bunch of companies that want to be
better creative you know more creative
or storytellers or whatever and replace
pixar with any company that's excellence
in x category and you just tell your
story as you always do and then that
becomes part of your slightly more
corporate repertoire that you know maybe
they don't want to hear the putin putin
story but they they want to hear the
pixar one
yeah so you select the people by who
will listen to this
and then pay me money to consult or work
backwards from that
yeah i'm gonna go to apple and give them
the
the putin speech and then all of a
sudden google employees start
mysteriously dying
i think i think this is good i think
that so right now you're uh you're
you're slumming it because you've got a
small business that you're just starting
and it's gonna take time to get going we
this will just supercharged it a little
bit i think
and by the way i always
whenever i give advice the way i explain
to people is i'm gonna say some things
that make you feel uncomfortable either
because you personally would feel
nervous saying the thing i just said to
a customer or quoting a pr quoting that
price to a customer the second reason is
your moral code says well that's not
what i want to do with my content i
don't want to feature pixar because i
want to give talks about pic you know
creativity and storytelling
okay cool i'm just telling you if you
crank the
commercialization like sellout knob to
12. here's what you could do and then
you could decide to dial that back to
nine uh or eight whatever you feel
comfortable with and uh i always say it
differently i say do you want your
future kids to have braces or not
like you ever been to an orthodontist my
friend it's expensive get to work
oh that's amazing
that's too good
all right let's do some other topics
thank you ben i appreciate the uh good
luck
i do appreciate the advice i really do
thanks guys
that's amazing right that that i was
thinking about that for like about a
week that's hilarious i had no idea that
was going on uh all right he mentioned
it to us but he didn't make a big deal
out of it what do you want to talk about
what do you want to talk okay um
i know what i want to talk about well i
don't know if this is interesting to you
but
i've noticed that your angel investing
is on a tear our friend suli just said
whatever sean
what did he what did he say whatever
sean joke he was like oh i got this new
brilliant investment strategy uh sean
invests in something and then he tells
me about it two weeks to two months
later and then i paid 10x price for the
same item for the same company it was
great which is and he's like anecdote
he was joking obviously obviously that's
not great he's like making fun of
himself because that's literally what's
happened in like i think six or eight
deals now
where i'll i'll even tell him about it
but he just delays responding for a
couple weeks or i forget to tell him and
i tell him or he tells me about the
company a few months later i'm like oh
yeah i invested in that he's like
awesome can you make an intro and i make
the intro and but the price has gone up
like dramatically because the company
has more traction or more whatever
so that's what he was joking about so i
we i put you on like an email list for
my friends where i'm sending you
everything are you getting those no i
didn't see anything
i sent you
two of them so far okay maybe i need to
i'll afford it to them one of them i'll
send you after this but anyway so i'm
i'm starting i'm i'm starting it off
where i'm sending them to you so you
gotta uh hopefully if you find something
that interests me you'll send back but
how are you getting such good
um i don't know like dude it's amazing
so i feel like there's i think the easy
answer is oh cool i do this podcast and
because of this podcast people come
inbound right the bigger this podcast
gets the more people
uh want you to invest and there's this
great um thing my buddy vishal taught me
when she goes
startups are the only asset class like
real estate doesn't work this way stock
market like in real estate if you want
to buy it you go buy it if you want
stock if you want to buy it you go buy
it startups are the only thing where
even if you want in you don't just get
in the security selects you the asset
selects you just as much as you're
selecting the asset and that one insight
is pretty important it basically means
you need to build your brand and your
like reputation so that people want you
in deals um because the best deals are
all like kind of
like super competitive to get into um
and you want people to when they're
first thinking of an idea to reach out
to you because they know oh you know
like for example i did a great deal
recently and it's so funny you're gonna
hate this it's gonna piss you off so
much
you've been talking about short-term
rentals
somebody came to me with a short-term
rental startup idea because they thought
i was you or something or somebody was
like hey
bro why didn't you send that to me
by the way the subject line that she
reached out with was last one in it was
like hey i have the smallest bit of
allocation left in this motherboard this
is a company called hostfully you'll
love it because it's it's literally
exactly what you're doing you should get
it i'll enter you
you will get in uh but but basically
what they're doing is you if you own a
bunch of airbnbs which is kind of like a
new market uh it's basically like you're
a property manager so you're more than
just renting out your home or one home
so you have multiple properties but
you're not a traditional property
manager who owns a multi-family you know
like uh building of like 32 units
and so this is for people who run
multiple airbnbs and it's just like it
makes your life way easier as the as the
owner of that and they have like few
million dollars in recurring revenue the
valuation was great founder was really
impressive so i was like oh yeah great
sas software for people who manage
multiple vacation rentals and then
you're over here building short sam
short-term rental club
building this community doing this thing
and i got the benefit because people
thought i was you that's that's one
answer the piss you off answer that's
ridiculous that is a piss me off answer
whatever it is what it is send me what
i'll send you what's the company called
can we talk about it yeah hostfully
host fully well then i can just email
her it's is it uh do they have a bunch
of uh uh vcs behind it or all angels um
i think this rounds a lot of individuals
i'm not sure it was like i was kind of
late to the party so i was just pretty
quick to just be like okay this makes a
lot of sense uh you know the once once
you have revenue and a few million
dollars that's recurring and they really
haven't even like figured out what their
marketing strategy is going to be yet
it's like okay that's a pretty good
signal that this is going to work and uh
it's a pretty indispensable tool for a
property owner so i like that one but i
would say okay here's here's some of the
things that have happened one is
when i share deals with you you share
deals with me my buddy julian shapiro
shares like some of the best deals um
he's just very active he's very like
consistent with it meaning like every
week he's sending me some good um
that's i would say 40 to 50 of the
portfolio is relationships with friends
who themselves are experts and
specifically people who are experts in
one niche so it's like
we've been doing a bunch of like sales
person software
and it's because we
like have a relationship with craft
ventures who it started by david sacks
he's kind of like the enterprise sas guy
he built yammer sold it for a billion
dollars his fund specifically just
focuses on sas companies and what
so david sends you stuff dave not me
particularly so my partner romine uh who
runs my fund he basically has a good
relationship somebody at graph so for
example when they're seeing something
good they're just trading notes all the
time and so we're getting to get in on a
lot of their deals so
if
are they giving you the deal because
they like shawn or they like romaine
in this case it's romaine because uh he
has that relationship he's catching up
with that guy every two weeks goes get
coffee or whatever it is and but then i
do the same with my guys right so i do
the same with the people in india or the
people in southeast asia because i'm
like i think that's where a lot of
opportunity is and that's where i have
the right relationships so we're sharing
stuff uh just amongst that
so
and then the other thing is like themes
so for example once i decide that a
theme is correct uh like worth worth
betting on what i learned from suli
actually is the level of aggression you
need to have once you decide x is a good
idea you need to go invest in that
company and then like the five other
companies that are like adjacent to it
so for example
um
there's this trend of banking like neo
banks right yeah so this started several
years ago
where people basically were like look
banks are something everybody uses but
has super low customer satisfaction
scores like
their apps sucked uh their marketing
sucked so basically people are like look
we can create like a digital first bank
and this started like new bank is is
probably the best example of this it's
in brazil they're like oh look yeah and
they're about to go people are under
bank there so they started a new bank a
friend of a friend of mine uh was like
led their investment and now it's a 10
billion dollar company and it has like
millions of customers in brazil and then
the same thing happened in the uk with
revolut and monzo whatever so this idea
of neo banking basically of
can you make super slick cus like slick
app for customers digitally market to go
get customers and basically you're
building um you're actually not building
the banking part you usually go partner
with like some bank like bbva or
something like that under the hood it's
bbva but the customer relationship is
with uh
with a company that's really good at
taking care of customers and building
good user experiences anyway so that's
the the short answer is like okay decide
that that's a good idea
um
and that takes many forms so like we
talked about this before like ramp or
brex these are like brexit i think was
the fastest growing yc company in the
last few years and you look at it you
say is this a good idea you say well
what are they actually doing they're
basically giving credit cards to some
group of people that were dissatisfied
with current credit card providers brex
did it for startups and they get a
portion of every time that card swipes
oh interesting so if a million people
are spending a thousand dollars a year
on it and they're keeping 1.3 of the
interchange fee of the debit card or
whatever you can come up with some
number you say wow this company's going
to get big pretty fast so we did that
math of neo banks how much is the neo
bank customer worth and how much is a
credit card customer worth and then we
went and did it in every niche we could
think of so we we invested in keep which
is doing this for canada and then we
invested in uh pluto which is doing this
in the middle east but but did you
holler at them yeah then we go search
and destroy basically it's like how do
you go hunt for the best companies that
are doing this in either this geography
or with this customer base so for
example and you just dm them on twitter
probably yeah exactly we just reach out
cold dm and say hey i'm a believer in
this for this system this reason what
you're doing looks super interesting
would love to invest and sometimes it
comes inbound sometimes it's oh you got
100 things inbound but you know what
you're looking for so you quickly pounce
on the four that fit your your thing
aren't you out of money at this point
from the fun though i raised more money
because i was like i was like before i
thought
dude uh you know will i get a million
dollars worth of deals every quarter
that are good deals i'm not just trying
to invest in crap so i need to invest in
good deals so i i was like i don't know
how many high quality deals i'll have
and now um
i realized that like whatever i whatever
i had before was too low so now we're
doing almost two million a quarter uh we
raised more money because we just had
better deals
man i because i'm starting so i started
angel investing almost one year ago well
i i did it five or eight companies
person the last
before that i forget and a couple of
them have turned out to be like
meaningful like turning 20 grand into
like 300 400 500 000 and i'm like holy
this is how it works
and like but like it it sucks for a
while right because you just invest it
you're like well that's money's gone and
you don't ever hear bottom and then
you're like oh
nice it works and so i'm like in some of
those cases those are huge markups in
other cases i'm just now experiencing
like two and three and four x markups
and i'm like that's awesome what would
happen if that was had i invested in
this company at a 10 million valuation
instead of a 50 million dollar
evaluation that would have been wild and
like how do i do that well one of the
reasons so i hated startup investing for
for a while because i was like you know
is this the best use of time and money
dude it feels like an expensive hobby
i'm just spending money and not getting
anything in return and then i then i
realized two things which is bezos has
this quote which i believe he goes
one of the biggest competitive
advantages you can have is being
long-term oriented basically if you
prioritize like if you have a 10-year
view where you're like okay i'm going to
maximize what i can do in 10 years and
the other guy is trying to make the most
they can make
you know for their quarterly earnings
call right this is how amazon worked
right amazon was basically like we're
willing to lose money
to invest so that we provide two-day
shipping instead of seven-day shipping
or free two-day shipping or
a larger selection but it's gonna cost
us more because we're gonna have more
inventory or whatever so we're going to
go into all these other verticals books
cds whatever
they basically said
like his strategy was long term this is
going to be the most valuable strategy
short term we're going to get punished
by the market because our quarterly
earnings are not going to look great
but that turned out to be the like magic
you know the sort of like the biggest
competitive advantage amazon had was
their ability to be long-term oriented i
think this is true just in general which
is if you're competing in somebody who
they need a result in one year and
you're willing to be patient and get the
result in five years seven years or ten
years
you can make bets that they can't make
so that means you get to have lower
price bets um that will pay off bigger
just over a longer time horizon so i
think if you have the luxury of a
long-term present that's a competitive
advantage that's how startup investing
works is
if you need money or you you need to see
positive growth in one year startup
investing sucks if you're willing to
play a 10-year game this can be an
awesome game to play and so do you think
that well but do you think you
you told me you're like man i think i
could three and a half x my fun because
that's average now it seems like it's
gonna be significantly more yeah like
you know you think about kind of like
what's the floor uh you know i think a
three and a half x would be
you know a a solid outcome but you know
nothing to write home about
um but like with a small fund like ours
you could see things where you can get a
15x you can get a 20x there are
literally crypto small funds like ours
that have had 100x they 100x the fund in
in the period of time right so so you
know you shouldn't really the ceiling is
high um but but the floor is is pretty
reasonable so the first thing was okay
long term oriented is a competitive
advantage i i like start professing for
that reason the second one is
you want to do things that compound so
for example if i wanted to beat the
market in the stock market right i want
to beat the s p 500 i need to have
proprietary like intelligent i need to
be smarter than anybody else about
something and i think just being smarter
at a game where money's on the line is
just really hard to do
whereas if you do um
if you basically say hey
my advantage comes from my reputation or
my my network of people that i know
that's just gonna compound every year
the more deals i share with you the more
deals you're gonna share with me the
more companies i have that are winners
that's gonna make it easier for me to
get into the next winner or for founders
to come reach out to me because they'll
say oh i saw you did these five indian
unicorns
i'm an india i want to be the next one
of them so you should inve can you
invest in me
so compounding also comes into play here
in a way that doesn't happen in the
stock market and doesn't even really
happen in real estate real estate has it
to an extent but but not in the same way
as how fast your reputation can compound
and start investing so anyways those are
my two reasons why i now actually view
startup startup investing as a as a game
worth playing because it it uses two of
the superpowers that uh that i believe
in that i think most people undervalue
is it gonna what do you think we'll earn
more the ecom thing or this angel
investing thing uh probably for me
personally the ecom thing because i just
own the majority of that company so you
know if it sells for fifty million
dollars or a hundred million dollars you
know i'll own the majority of it but uh
whereas with startup investing you know
it's like my fund invests a hundred
thousand dollars we own point eight
percent of this startup i personally
have twenty percent of the carry but
then i share with romaine and ben and
zach so i personally own
14 point something percent of the carry
or whatever sure you know so it's not
like you know you're owning a slice of a
slice of something big versus just
owning them you know how it is owning
the majority of something that sells for
a decent chunk is is just better
financially
it's so much better and
yeah i think that whenever people raise
money i'm like are you sure man you
might be able to sell this for 50
million dollars and you'll make more
money than if you raise money and sell
for 500. yeah exactly now you know but i
have to operate that other business
whereas startup investing is like you
know a joy right you just read about
cool ideas you meet meet awesome
founders and you say yes you write the
check and then they go do the hard work
so it's a you know just a different
thing
can i you brought up uh sdr's short term
that's what i they're called short-term
rental sers have you researched that at
all so i joined your club but uh
crazy right did you do two
things did you used to review it yeah i
was i'm i've been looking at some of
these posts dude did you see like it's
like techy guys it's like people who
have like 100 million dollar company by
the way i don't know how you founder of
facebook but like every time i open
facebook whatever you're working on is
always the top post on my feed i
don't know if facebook just knows that i
love you but like
if it was true
at the top if it's sam talking about his
cold plunge it's sam's video of his cold
plunge naked at the top like you know
the what hits in the facebook algorithm
in a way that like i don't understand
i've always been like that it's always
been that way for some reason i mastered
facebook and that sucks because it's the
least valuable uh
i figured out what you're talking about
wow
because i can only have five thousand
friends on facebook yeah doesn't matter
your groups are big okay so but tell me
what that group is sick right how many
people are saying a thousand thousand
people in this group and people are
basically posting hey guys
here's the properties i own and they
show a bunch of cool photos my strat
like for example my family owned five
big short-term rentals in kissimmee
florida which is five miles from disney
world so his strategy is basically
airbnb near disney world i have a
full-time job i'm a phd student blah
blah and um
and uh and then they're showing like
these uh disney themed rentals that they
have and people go ask questions at the
comments and then everybody's got this
like you know you're doing your your
magic thing where everybody feels
comfortable telling you how much money
they're making and uh everyone's sharing
a bunch of good info so so i think
that's really cool
what i wanted to hear from you is give
me the top two most interesting stories
that you've learned i'm gonna tell you
i uh i've gotta be a little subliminal
about this um so in that group
there's 11 or 100 or a thousand people i
met one person that's got 35 million
dollars in homes he owns about 20 of
them
and he's currently making
about a million close to a million
dollars a month in profit and was this
person wealthy before this how do you
get to the 35 million dollars worth of
real estate they were mildly wealthy
they were worth probably 15 million
dollars they had a business that they
sold yes they were not poor and
they invested a lot of it into into into
short-term rentals and now they have a
staff of a couple people who are
full-time
and his take is like 800 grand a month
and i met another guy who worked at a
hedge fund and his name's richard if you
google richard he'll tell he has a story
in there and he
eventually quit his hedge fund now he
owns 50 million dollars worth of
short-term rental rentals and the themes
that i'm seeing are this one
institutional capital has not come into
short-term rentals a significant amount
two
the numbers might be inflated because
the economy is crushing
but i'm not entirely sure if that is
totally the case but definitely could be
the case
three
a couple years ago it was people were
just buying places without doing much
math and the math like worked out when
you they're making 25 returns it's crazy
now it's a little bit more challenging
but it's still a lot of opportunity
and uh
it's sick man like i i've been learning
all about it it's wild so of all the
things you've read in here what uh
what what seemed like the smartest what
i'll call small ball strategy so throw
out the guy who's had 15 million bucks
and now he's built this big thing who's
done a small ball start small grow grow
it and maybe in some niche that's a cool
cool story out of this or you don't say
who but what is the what do they do is a
million dollars considered small so if
you buy property for a million dollars
you're going to put down 150 grand for
some of these guys there's a guy in
there
yeah if you go are you in the group
right now
search the word coconut
there's a guy who bought a plot of land
on a it was a coconut farm in mexico and
he put
four i think tiny homes and he rents
them for 150 a day uh in mexico and he
did really nice landscaping but not
complicated stuff it looks beautiful do
you see it
is it uh
something farms yeah can i say the name
or no safa farms yeah yeah yeah safa
farms
so click it so six cabbages created this
like so so it says a tiny eco hotel farm
six cabins one house an in-ground fire
pit at a pool in mexico and uh it looks
cool it's basically like a bunch of
wooden cabins that look like really
small
you know one-person two-person kind of
stays and then like really cool outdoor
area with hammocks and
pools and uh you know common areas and
places to go do yoga with like chickens
running around you
is that wild and he talked about it in
the post i don't think he spent a
significant amount of money to set that
up but he just it's minimalist ish it's
kind of nice but it's definitely
minimalist
but it's it's lovely and so that's a
really cool thing i've seen a guy like
that like that is really interesting and
what they do is they go and stay there a
couple weeks out of the year dude how
cool is airbnb that it created this
opportunity for anybody to say hey look
if you can create an awesome experience
for people
like a great a great place to stay a
unique way a place to stay
we will give you money you will be able
to make money just by creating this cool
little farm and huts set up in uh
villa corona
mexico
and uh
how sick is that and then on the other
side it's like hey you want to travel
here's the here's the the buffet of
like dope experiences that's not just
cookie cutter hotel that you can go stay
at like how sick is airbnb that's just
it's in respect it's amazing
it's amazing and what i'm learning is so
basically the order of importance is
when you're looking for it's just like
content it's just like scrolling through
youtube and so if you look at it through
that lens you can make a lot of money
for example when you're buying a
property you go on zillow and you look
at their thumbnail pictures you're like
what catches my eye and then if you
don't see anything there you're like all
right that nothing here but like oh they
took a bad picture here but if they
changed the angle here and they made the
light at sunset this will look beautiful
and so you're basically shopping for
thumbnails and uh
and then the second thing that you're
wanting to do is you're not shopping in
any place in which you have to create
demand and so you use air dna and it
shows you who has the highest book and
booking rate and then um the third thing
you do is you pick a very specific niche
and you have one unique thing about the
property for example you call it a zen a
zen thing because you've got like a
little pond on the front or what i'm
gonna do is you call it like has a fancy
gym or has a putt-putt course or has uh
like one unique thing right right
like deck with view of sunset and so you
want that one unique thing and that's
the same thing that's the same way how
content because it lets you reimagine
okay if this home was not for a family
of four to live every day and go to go
to the grocery store and come home well
then maybe this little space instead of
a you know a living room that's about
you know just two couches and a tv it's
like maybe this is actually where
companies are gonna come for their
retreats and it's actually gonna be
different groups of 25 at a time and
they need a big sauna in one area and
then they need a pool area and a
barbecue pit that's like i will over
invest on these things and i will i
don't need to have these daily utility
functional things that a normal house
would need
right and it's just been so fascinating
because i didn't realize how many like
tech nerds are into this stuff that
group is so cool it's so interesting and
uh anyway we don't we can move on but i
thought i thought that was i thought
it's just an interesting world that i'm
falling into so like you know rohan from
pricinomics
he basically
he didn't tell me this but it appears as
though price economics is on the back
the back burner and all of his time is
on short-term rentals and he owns like
seven of them
um
it's it's badass man it's a super
interesting market yeah i just want to
give money to this group and just be
like hey uh
you know
anybody who wants to like trick out
their their place and you know whatever
or buy their next property hey i'll just
finance it with you and share cash flow
if you want to you know how you can have
some preferred return that's fine so
that is the thing that's interesting to
me there's no such thing or there aren't
many funds so like you and i have
invested i think you did as well in like
a blackrock like investment fund that
like buys like 500 walgreens and they
just make five percent
there should be one of those for
short-term rentals just because if you
believe in that category you can have a
reit or skin in the game somehow that's
passive right yeah that's wild um okay
let's do let's do one other thing uh
uh
let's see i got a couple let me give you
um
let's do let's do two quick ones okay um
tailgate guys have you ever heard of
this business
so this this came up at farm con so i go
to this dinner with this guy he listens
to the pod
and he was telling me i was like you
know uh i was trying to make small talk
at this dinner where i was like okay i
hate normal small talk like i'm not just
gonna oh yeah how's the conference going
good yeah good how about you good good
um and i also don't know anything about
farming so like it's not relevant to me
so you know okay i can ask them a bunch
of questions you like corn too yeah
exactly you know i don't have much to
add so what's your favorite type of corn
so i was a bit of an ice breaker i was
like um
i was like first job like what was your
first first job first first first i
don't know i asked did you have a side
hustle in college
and i went around the table i was like
did you have a side because everybody
was doing something different now and
they're all established now but did you
when you were in college have a side
hustle and everybody had an interesting
one so this i put that in my question
bank of like ah interesting uh you know
fun little combo when you're in a kind
of entrepreneurial group
so one guy tells a story he goes yeah
dude i um
i think he went to like ole miss or like
what alabama or like one of these like
southern football colleges
and he's like i created a um like
tailgate in a box like what he's
basically like yeah like tailgating is
huge before the football game people go
to the parking lot and they want to
grill and drink and play beer pong and
do all the stuff
and um he's like you know for he's like
my family used to like to do it so he's
like first my family it was so
competitive so you had to go wait like
kind of overnight to get your spot he's
like so they would send me i'd have to
go down to the i forgot what was called
the grove or something like that and i'd
have to wait in the parking lot and hold
my family spot
then i started to be like okay cool you
got the spot well like well you got to
set up the tailgate for us like come on
we need uh tables for beer pong and we
need this and that so he's like okay
i'll i'll get the stuff every week and
i'll go do it and he would create a good
setup and then the
space next to him was like hey dude
can we next week can we just will you
set ours up and he's like all right uh
you give me like 200 bucks i'll get you
guys some stuff like yeah sure
and then the price goes up and he's like
oh my i can basically charge each little
tailgating square like each little group
of friends
500 to just set up a cool tailgate spot
for them turnkey tailgating and so he
did this at his college and he's like
dude i was making thousands and
thousands of dollars every semester
running this um and i was like is it i
googled tailgate guys did it get
acquired so so that was their competitor
so there was a nationwide version of
this he was doing this at small scale
that was his college side hustle just to
make a little bit of money he's like
yeah tailgate guys tried to come in
but uh they couldn't break into our
market like we owned our market and i
was like who's tailgate guys he's like
oh these guys basically took this idea
and they started doing it nationwide and
i was like that's really smart he goes
yeah
but how does it work do you have like
you just hire college kids and you say
we'll give you 50 50 an hour for three
hours on saturday we get 50 you get 50
exactly and then do they do the kids go
to like walmart and buy the stuff i
think either you give them the supplies
in bulk or um or they have to go grab it
and you tell them hey you need to get
this table and these bowls and this beer
this whatever whatever and you use like
a company credit card something that has
exactly and so tailgate guy and what
they do
the key is they would partner with the
school they would say hey we'd like to
be the exclusive uh tailgate provider
for the school
and the school would give them the
license and so they had a monopoly and i
was like what
and it's like yeah actually this is
pretty common that schools will
basically pick one
vendor provider they'll sell the license
rights basically they'll let you become
the official you know north carolina you
know
you know the tar heels they link to you
instead you call it tar heel tailgate
and it's like their thing and you pay
them a fee or a revenue share of what's
going on but in exchange you get a
monopoly you get to be the only provider
of this and it's like super viral
right because you're just like everybody
sees wow that setup looks not bootleg
what is that oh they use tailgate guys
or whatever okay cool we should use them
next time
and uh so tailgate guys apparently like
i think they got bought out by private
equity or something but they um
they were doing like i don't know
30 to 50 million dollars a year doing
this what and um and i thought what a
great
example of a college hustle that you
then scale up you say all right if this
works at my college it's going to work
at every college and every college that
has a football program that has
tailgating and then we have this
repeatable sales model of going to the
university and we tell them hey these
other eight universities partnered with
us
we'd like to partner with you you get
extra income and we will provide a safe
uh you know convenient way for your your
fans to do this i thought that's pretty
this is a really cool little niche
business and then i started thinking
well what are the other ones what are
the other businesses that use the same
sales tactic of basically
partnering with the school and becoming
the exclusive provider so we had a
little mini brain mini because the guy
listens to the podcast so we had like a
mini brainstorm session at dinner where
he's like dude this is happening also
with scooters uh when like bird and lime
came out in cities
companies decided oh shoot we should
become the exclusive scooter provider on
campus like we'll go
drop these scooters all everywhere it'll
be branded by this with the school the
school will get a rev share for every
scooter ride that happens and we get a
captive market that nobody can compete
with us in and so this started happening
with scooters and i was like oh damn
what else could be done because scooters
is cool because it's a new category
right tailgating worked because it was a
new category so you just have to think
about like what's something today that
they don't even really have a um
like an option for like they're not
really there isn't really like a market
for it you're creating the market what
did he say well we were kind of
brainstorming you know he's like you
know one of the hard things is now
schools have gotten slightly wise to it
they won't give the license up super
easily meaning like they want to make
sure they get a fair shake so once you
come to them with the idea they're like
great hold on 90 day proposal request
for proposal period where we're going to
go like
see who wants to offer this to us so
we're going to go talk to five companies
before we just say yes to you but in the
good old days you used to be like oh
they should be like sure you know you
came to us so you get the deal
i um
i i've learned a little bit about um
selling to schools i i
you frozen oh there you are i sent you
uh this company it's called kira cubby
it's kind of a bad name pure cubby but
basically it's i just sent it to you
actually i told joe to send it to you do
you see it no
and what they do is it's like the most
boring thing ever so basically this guy
uh stephen he had an autistic kid his
kid was diagnosed with autism and he
goes i don't feel like sending him to a
normal school i don't think they're
gonna do anything so he started a school
and he like 20 kids in the neighborhood
went to the school and he was like man
managing this school so first of all
that's amazing second of all he was like
man's school is that pain in the ass
right and so he so he found another
parent in he lives in oakland so the
other parents are like tech guys and he
found uh this guy who sent his kid to
his school and they decided to build
this software together that basically
makes it really easy to collect tuition
payment and also pay your bills so
basically like a bill.com or and then
plus a quickbooks and then plus
eventbrite so you can like check into
after school programs and stuff like
that and they are crushing it and it's
just four guys and they got it up to
like 2.4 million in revenue recurring
revenue and
but he's telling me all about selling
into schools and it sounds like a
nightmare selling into a school yeah i
think it is uh you know the company who
i think has done the best of this is
mystery science have you seen them
is that like a tv show what is that kind
of okay so basically
um oh wow they got acquired i didn't
realize this they got acquired last year
no way 140 million dollars good for them
they um okay so this
the what mystery science was doing was
they were like all right um how do we
make
uh like entertaining videos sort of like
uh
you know i don't know pick your favorite
analogy like blues clues or
um
whatever you know reading rainbow or
whatever the hell that's called um magic
school bus whatever and basically it's
on every topic so if you're like you
know how do why are plants green so
they're like we start with a question
that any kid would have why are plants
green or like um
you know how hot is the sun
and they're like we're gonna make the
definitive most entertaining simple
answer to that question and it turns
into in some ways like a it's like a
game where it's like
the teacher can just pick one of those
questions and be like hey class today
here's the question who wants to know
the answer to this everyone's like yeah
me i want to know the answer like great
we're going to like have this little
worksheet and this video and the video
is gonna like tease us part of it and
then we have to go figure out the next
bit then we watch the next bit of the
video so it makes it easy for the
teacher to like teach a question that
people are really interested in and they
reached like four and a half million
teachers countrywide like i think at one
point
30 or 40 percent of all elementaries
were using them so they had like dude
how did they only sell for 150 million
incredible um penetration it was it was
absolutely insane
um
they i don't know why they sold for 140
million but i know that they basically
raised very little money and they were
super profitable and so i think you know
for the guys they probably made you know
over 100 million dollars off this deal
and um
[Music]
you know they raised i think they raised
only four million dollars like a
lifetime
uh it was a bit old they started in 2014
so you know seven seven years or so um
and i think you know charging money is
always is always hard but uh
but these guys are super smart talk to
the guy keith and i just really
respected what they had built i thought
wow what a cool product
amazing that they've gotten this level
of saturation and it was like the way
they sold was it was like um you know
like bottoms up in a way i think uh
where like teacher it was just so like
teachers couldn't help but talk about it
to other teachers because they were like
oh this is amazing it's like normally
when i wheel out the tv well yeah it
makes your job way easier so guilty i'm
like copping out it's like yeah we're
gonna watch a movie today class was like
this is different this is like it's
interactive it's based on questions it's
based on science and they're like we're
just going to teach science this way and
um yeah i thought it was amazing
that's so good this um yeah they reach
50 of the u.s elementary school market
which is how much revenue were they
making wild
i don't know at the time i was talking
to them they were doing like somewhere
between between 10 and 20 million in
revenue profitably um
and did they make money through ads or
they like sold workshops so they sell
the like subscription i think to them it
was a subscription so to the software
dude how do you reach that many teachers
but only have and only sell for 140.
that's crazy to me yeah i don't know um
just wild anyways uh i gotta run dude i
got a call with this uh crazy crypto
thing that i'm trying to get into so i
want to see if i can do that
all right we'll talk soon oh uh all
right sean if you want to leave you can
leave i think ben do i got to read out
some names yes
um
actually just one name
all right we did this thing where we
gave 60 minutes of shaun and i's time
what did the person have to do to win
uh they had to review rate and review us
on apple podcast
great and the winner is
is it ss
yes
spencer scott you are the winner has
spencer he follows me on twitter he
always replies to my stuff does he know
that he won other than right now
yeah i told him
nice all right spencer scott's a winner
last week we gave the winner for the
tick tock thing so we did this tic tac
thing where if you made videos on any
platform and you use the mfm clip uh
hashtag you you could win five grand we
gave
three did we get three or two
two
uh and then before that we did a contest
where if you read and review us you won
60 minutes with shawn and i so we gave
you that one to spencer scott and we're
gonna keep doing these we're not doing
it yet but we're gonna keep doing them
so
that's the episode that's the winner
check it out
[Music]
you